the jurgen experience
you uh giving people smelling salts is
you need to do that to every single cat
you want to try it yeah yeah you need to
try it it's just ammonia right we have
it over there jamie jamie's got it it's
just ammonia right is it
super ammonia oh well it's uh
you know who juju mufu is
yeah the fight
no he's like a like a power lifter dude
he's [ __ ] right uber jack he does it
before he works yeah and it's his
company
and i think it's called ah or something
like that something crazy like that it's
so ridiculous like you wait you're not
gonna believe how ridiculous it is like
you take a sniff and you're like what
kind of scared how the [ __ ] are you
selling this
everybody who tries it gets shocked i
i guess they do is they do the smelling
salts to jack up their central nervous
system and then they lift all right let
me start my heart rate monitor oh yeah
yeah get that heart rate monitor going
okay here we go
heart rate monitor that's on
it's on okay what's it what's it showing
now
uh hold on it's measuring
98. okay let's calm down okay you're a
little high right now
98's a little high just like i know
you're anticipating this but i want a
real good reaction
i want a real one i don't wanna i want
an elevated heart rate to begin with
okay all right you ready yeah okay i'm
gonna hand it to you screwed on oh god
scared dude
unscrew it yourself i'm scared and then
take a nice big deep whiff and don't be
a [ __ ]
oh my god right oh oh my god marshall's
up
marshall's checking in on you look how
sweet he is i'm okay mark how sweet he
is okay he's checking in on you
here we go
it's not bothering you it's wrong
it wasn't as strong as i thought it was
going to be it's not as strong anymore
is it weakening yeah 100 i'll have to
test it you got lucky [ __ ]
you got lucky we haven't still got me i
think we have another one we never i
think it has to be unopened try it
marshall's free still got me no it ain't
that bad man it ain't that bad
right that's not not nearly something
happened no yeah not nearly not nearly
okay yeah you wouldn't be able to no no
no dude that reaction you had to that
buckle up oh god i took a hit big buck
we're gonna get the other one two
seconds let me see it must dry out or
something that makes sense i mean how
how long could that possibly last it's
still pretty nasty it's [ __ ] insane
what is that i've smelled that before
imagine what it's like to him oh he
probably smells it right now he's
probably like what the [ __ ] are you
doing at me here he's looking at the
door oh now he's licking himself
constantly hey get out of there sir
oh yeah that ain't [ __ ] but uh when you
get the new one hopeful hopefully they
can find the new one so what's the
difference between that and the the
the crack i think it's the same same
thing no no well there's poppers which
is amyl nitrate that's what the gay
people do to have butt sex how dare i
mean that's what they do you go you go
to western people have done it too oh
really but yeah i think gay people do it
primarily so that's the same thing as
poppers as that yeah wow that was a big
party drug in the gay community right
that a lot of people were attributing to
diminishing people's immune systems and
wrecking your your body and causing
brain damage it's really [ __ ] bad for
you when jamie comes back we'll google
like that the health effects of of
poppers of a male nitrate it's really
really bad for you but that's not this
stuff this stuff is like the stuff they
use to wake people up when they've been
knocked out
smelling sauce it's like pneumonia it's
like a like a strong pneumonia smell
like what you just got it ain't [ __ ]
jesus it ain't [ __ ] wait till you get a
full whip god i hope that we're not
building up something that doesn't exist
anymore
because if somebody took it these things
are just laying around here sometimes so
you need to have it every single guest
just have hey you want to try one no
scientists and
to be continued on the next time red
band is here we will have procured a
solid supply of such items